citizens of the reject Nation we are here to
continue our Brooklyn nine nine Journey episode
14 of season five Greg how you doing how you
feeling fine John good fine leave a like for
being fine subscribe if you're feeling three out
of five and uh join the patreon if you want to see
the full length reactions of these episodes watch
along with us a lot of fun let's do this thing
um
what the hell is going on
setting up an interrogation oh Sterling K Brown
I'm Phillip Davidson detective Jake Paul to ask me
to drop off Ben just too murdered someone I think
he did it can you show him to interrogation room
C please have fun in there thank you and he does
have excellent teeth how uncomfortable this guy is
jacked up the thermostat got the table all sticky
made one of the chair legs too short and worst of
all I had Gina greet him what did you however do
be yourself of course son of a [__] yeah Kevin
and I are attending the Opera oh the Opera is it
the one Bugs Bunny sings yes so who's this this
is Philip Davidson the Opera tonight irrigation
for the ticketing clock and everything on the
line I better call Kevin and tell him I won't
be attending the Opera there's someone else I'd
rather hear saying oh and I won't be joining
your driver tonight uh [Laughter] it's gonna be
a bottle episode all in one room with no subplots
you're right he did it but we have no murder
way you really didn't find any usable forensic
evidence the body was discovered rotting in the
shoot up by Coyotes the only other DNA other than
the vix was some bear semen found in the hair Ryan
who found the body you're really gonna just blow
past the bear seam in detail I imagine a bear
mistook the rotting corpse for a female of its
species and had intercourse with it nothing
happens yeah I've been there Geraldo do you
know what I miss most about being a detective a
good interrogation breaking suspects down talking
quietly and then talking real loud a lot of these
techniques do work better with two people you know
good cop bad cop Crazy Cop saying cop fast talking
StreetWise cop in Hong Kong cop AKA The Rush Hour
you know what let's do this let's break this up
Rush Hour Rush Hour this this is Captain Raymond
Holt he's a bit of a legend in interrogation
circles Hey cap who's the scariest person you've
ever gotten a confession out of Connie buttons
okay thought it was going to sound a little
cooler but no matter the night that Robert Tepper
was murdered you were the last person to see him
alive correct no I'd imagine whoever killed him
some after I did oh nice Dodge so cool he could
teleport around the ring most people thought it
was impossible to get past him I beat him every
time you just punch him when he gets dizzy really
I mean duh genus and anesthesiologist had gone
home and Grace Who usually locks up and left early
because her grandson had a school play so it was
just you and Robert Robert just wanted to talk
about firing one of our office assistants show
and that's all you discuss yeah yeah would you
like to hear what he said the meeting was about
7 P.M talk missing meds uh yeah how'd you know
that I think that's hardly sounds like firing
Cheryl so maybe you want to but how do you know
what his calendar said I'd like to move on unless
you have any other big revelations in here let's
see if I'm Gomez you're Morticia I feel so happy
when I'm with you yeah bars Partners but it was
Robert's name on the business correct he started
the practice and then I joined after something's
come up in the case can I talk to you on time for
a sec totally undermined me I apologize but
he's dancing I'll Badger him with my Superior
intellect while simultaneously belittling you once
Philip dismisses you as a threat I'll leave you
alone with him and he'll let his guard I would
say you're describing smart cop dumb cop look
I thought you had him on the counter yeah that's
the rush hour yeah so Chris Tucker would be smart
this time so what do you want me to do ask stupid
questions stupid questions grammatical errors lose
your train of thought just ask them to confess
relate everything back to those movies you've seen
kind of seems like a shot at me about die hard
but okay oh me want to dumb cop I got that yeah
well done it's gonna be like a play with Robert
in the surgical Suite one at your office I was
just preparing for the next day's surgery so you
have an assistant who does that I'm a meticulous
person careful how I do things so careful that
you I'm sorry I forgot what I was gonna say it
had undergone industrial sterilization to remove
all traces of blood it's surgical Suite people
bleeding there every day we have to sanitize
it by law I remember what I was going to ask
I said yes I would have had you I went to a bar
the Scotchman I didn't want to drive drunk so I
took a cab you didn't have your phone I left the
charging in my office and I didn't realize till
I was already out of the building oh man if I
go 10 wow oh if I had it on me you could have
seen a pinging off the cell tower it doesn't
matter didn't have it on me so you took a cab
he is taking such advantage of knowing he's
not caught don't you think maybe we should
just wait till your boss comes back oh you'd
like that wouldn't you because you're scared
you know I'm playing Hardball except for that the
balls are questions and did you kill him and what
did your cab driver look like this seems like
a huge waste of time Robert drove a sob Dana's
head was blind and sterilized on Wednesdays and
Saturdays I haven't been to burning in 20 years oh
man kill him and the cab driver had a beard in the
earring I'm sorry I didn't get his license number
this guy seems like a master manipulator
you didn't fall for my did you kill him
Gambit no although it is interesting you
knew the body was found in Vernon New
York when that information hasn't been
released to the public hey hey hey yeah
Dolly
nice way to pick up on the details I was the
dumb cop I mean I've watched planet Earth with
the British narrator [Music] actually Robert's
wife told me I've been talking with her a lot
comforting her we asked her not to share that info
this is everything with his slick smile yeah my
uncle has a cabin there I would visit him as a kid
so your uncle owns a cabin in the town that the
body was found I haven't been there for 20 years
you can call my uncle if you want so you might
as well just confess now or we can take our sweet
time the Majestic sleuth we don't have them but I
just told him we did have him Phillip's uncle
said he hasn't been to the cabin in months and
he hasn't spoken to Philip in over a year damn
it God damn it but if he hasn't been in months
Philip doesn't know that he's rattled right now if
we tell him the neighbor saw him that put his feet
up for you to stand behind me and say like three
oh damns when I really get cooking all right fine
two o dams one odam there will be no there will
be no dams at the very end uh you're guessing what
happened that night but what if Philip never went
to the cabin he did I can feel it here my gut your
gut or intestines is lower you should Point down
here closer to your pubis I'm guessing yes if Mad
Dog Peralta will do that who knows what else he's
capable of you don't get angry well what that's
not true remember how angry I got about how fast
Daenerys got from Dragonstone to north of the wall
true that some of those are scary count chocula
much all right fine I see your point what do you
suggest let's get all up in the personal space
make them feel uncomfortable okay fine let's
get intimate yeah Sam it's been like four
hours three hours three hours what was on
Fallon highlights what was he doing slow jam
in the news who was the guess you got some
old silver fillings in there you probably want
to drill those out replace them with porcelain
okay close some serious plaque buildup let's
get back to it no no open-minded let me see oh
not only did we not break them but
now I have to go to the dentist
Dental talk is giving me an idea okay 11 16.
it's funny when people call dentist Doctor we
are doctors we do four years of medical school
it's called dental school but we learned about
the entire body but if you had cancer you can
call it dentist you know it's actually harder to
get in the dental school than medical school oh
my God you are Riley him up most people want to
become actual doc that's ridiculous it's not like
we're College professors calling ourselves doctors
not the same thing my friend sure it is medical
practitioners have co-opted the word okay Captain
I know we live in a world where anything can mean
anything and nobody even cares about at the moment
I thought it was a good tactic yeah I know I
thought I was gonna break them his middle name's
Henry Robert Henry Tucker his wife called him
Rob work that in robbed up work it into full name
Robert Rob Henry tough now trying not to Blink so
tears come into your eyes man this guy is a good
murderer there's gonna be some way to break him
wait a minute two three four he brought the guitar
back wow yeah I really gotta stop trying that it
never works I almost worked on Kid Cudi he always
tries it on the black people I know Skip the
Opera has anything to do with him not believing
in you oh my God that's good why do you make you
dumb cop he didn't make me dumb cop not if it's
any of your business oh no why wasn't he done
complete you never would have bought this that
um between the two of us you were more believable
as uh them yes dumb uh the the number of twos kick
his ass kill your captain pretty sure it was
you honestly it could have been any one of our
employees they all have access to the storage room
you know it's silly but uh I trust the people who
work for me yeah because I want him here really
are you in charge and all those strategies you've
been coming after me with those were all your
ideas guitar thing was mine and you signed off
and you're gonna spend the rest of your life in
prison everyone who loves you will leave and you
will die alone and at that time it will be your
head that a bear has sex with oh yeah yeah take
him serious angry but if my body just seems like
when a muppet gets upset the Stars growing like
oh you want angry I'll show you angry oh God
this guy has just really gotten under my skin
I'm gonna go to the bathroom and try and clear my
head I think that's a good idea good [__] it out
oh he's gonna walk in the interrogation
room yeah what are you doing guess what
your uncle's neighbor saw you go into the cabin
tonight but my uncle only has one neighbor and
I'm pretty sure he didn't identify me because
he's been dead three years I'm friends with
Steph Curry you dumbass oh you were lying
in an attempt to frame my client no no no
no no look even if we who knows you screwed up
and my client's leaving he can't leave until I
dismiss him you've had him for 10 hours and
45 minutes then I'll just keep him for 14
minutes seriously just to be childish are you
doing it's not about everyone okay ABC stuff
to make it quick you only got eight minutes all
right then let me paint you a picture I'm Phillip
a successful periodontist that's become addicted
to diazepam a sedative I take because I'm junkies
where are we going no one day I'm working late
when my boss Robert surprises me he found out
I was stealing meds again Chucky's gone also
again not your fault there's a major genetic
component to addiction he says he's going to file
a police report a lot about this Peralta Yelp shot
has six of these heavy Looking Glass awards
from the Brooklyn periodontics Society in the
background this shot only has five what happened
to number six murdered Robert with him you lost
all control oh dang you were in the surgical
Suite it can be sterilized you never would
have gotten away with it in your carpeted office
and your office manager would have heard all of
the screaming but she was at her grandson's play
lucky again you're wrong you put Robert's body oh
Escape he's breaking I believe what you've done
you're flustered he has a place there you're the
luckiest son yes it was you got lucky at every
turn no I knew exactly where I was driving yeah
yeah you can use some glass of water if you
idiot but clearly see what's missing I made
a ride out of a special dental polymer yes
it's already in a patient's mouth son oh damn
oh damn oh damn there it is 30 dams all
three you had the wrong murder weapon
talking to you I realized what Philip's worst
fear actually was that we would think he was
just some dummy that got lucky he had planned
the perfect crime and it killed him when you
said he was sloppy and impulsive he needed us
to know how smart he was yeah Kevin [Laughter]
thank you sir let's go get some sleep hey
guys my goodness we're almost late for work
well well in that case good morning sir
good morning bro oh what a sweet scene
with that crane shot all right team you know I I
think we should just talk about this one okay I
know we've been doing two a week but I'm making
an executive decision here oh you're Captain
halting me right now yeah yeah dumbass okay let's
just review the episode yeah let me get my guitar
that was very special yeah that was a terrific
and I kind of feel like I don't know if the next
one is gonna compliment it completely this seems
like a very Standalone episode yeah this feels
exceptionally Standalone it just doesn't feel
right to start again I love how they actually
got Sterling K Brown for this yeah and and and
he was like it feels like it was written for him
I I wonder how this episode came to be because
absolutely I mean it's very much you're not like
famous enough to have something written for like
if you're like that famous but he might know some
people involved where they did like or people
who are fans of his work and they're like yeah
we we customize it because he was two perfect
yeah it was obnoxiously perfect yeah yeah and
and a real character a real character and and
plus you know no subplots or anything is just
the three of them pretty much except for the
lawyer the entire time so like yeah this feels
like some kind of event episode or something
even though I I I'm fascinated yeah to if you
guys know comment below because he he was just
such Perfect Chemistry with the two of them and
the game across the board was just so much fun
to watch and to watch him like you know really
get to uh play a character obviously but like it
just seemed like he was able to have the most fun
like really settling in and just feeling himself
and and you know riding that wave you know yeah uh
that was an absolute Delight of an episode yes I
I feel like this is like an S tier b99 like this
is like a top it's very special this is this is
it was like halfway through I'm like this is one
of my favorite episodes 100 yeah because it it
never sacrificed comedy the comedy would come
unexpectedly it seemed like the interior sometimes
the Dr if they're doing like an actual genre heavy
episode The Comedy is still comes front and center
and then the the subsidiary genre is the thing
that is uh you know it's not like an afterthought
or a second thought it's just not the main it's
not the main focus where here it actually felt
like that was the main focus yeah yeah and then
the comedy would come naturally because the
Rhythm was like so much like a play that I was
finding myself even impressed with Andy Samberg
especially Andy Samberg this time yeah because
you know sometimes on network TV you kind of learn
your lines a day before or something like that
but I'm like this must have taken some serious
rehearsal yeah no they were so synced up and and
everybody played their role in the frustrations
so yeah and they say you can't handle the tooth
which I thought was interesting because I was like
well this sort of feels like an Aaron's working
play yeah 100 yeah totally and and that's I like
I wonder yeah what what the construction of that
was in form not just around Sterling K brown but
whether they wanted to like specifically be like
oh we haven't done like an actual bottle episode
or something or if there were like complications
of like oh we can only keep like some of the
cast isn't available it still gets to him in
a way of how Tom Cruise gets the jacket yeah yeah
well that's the smart like that's the smart dumb
thing is is yeah you know people and and you know
Killers certainly serial killers they say like
yeah you want to be recognized for your Ingenuity
and uh and yeah it's like it's all character based
it's all about luring and drawing drawing out and
probing at the characters and for so much of it
you're watching is yeah he gets under their skin
until they finally figure it out and even that
the timing of that him going in and grabbing the
pictures really quick I was like okay this could
go in a cute Direction where it's just like oh
magically I figured it out but I even bought
the resolution by the end that sort of stroke of
of wisdom of of sort of inspiration of it being
yeah not just you know creating a different sort
of FIB with the award but realizing oh yeah yeah
yeah like the thing that we've been having so much
friction over is you know being made to look dumb
or or feeling like yeah we are you know sloppier
than we actually are and using that against him
was just like a really clever thing to do and
it was one of those things where where you know
the the comedy it just felt like a complete blend
like a really natural blend of a game that we want
to see cracked you know it's like it's really
easy to pull you in with that um and then also
slip in the comedy and really fun and interesting
ways but that always has like an intensity and a
momentum about it yeah I I really I really loved
I like I think Sterling K Brown you've kind of a
just epic performance here because he he
he's all about the is all about everything he
it's like this Debonair quality you know that
he has to always put up at this like always
keep himself composed no matter what it's like I
said we're going 10 hours into the middle of the
night and he's got to be the guy who has his
[__] together and there's such a Cockiness
to him yeah they're so cocky there's a whole time
like the entire time when he's being interrogated
he's got this smile of just yeah you guys know
I did it I know I did it but I can outwit you
the entire time it all comes down to evidence and
technicalities and all these things so you just
plain and simple I'm just I'm too smart for you
guys yeah and and so he's just having fun he is
taunting the whole time uh it's really clever and
you know and it is he can't show when he's being
worn down at all but but I love how they would
give like these little hints and these little
misleads like I was so into it when you're like
okay this is gonna be the thing that gets him to
get him to confessed when when Holt is going I
mean like Andre bro fantastic again like to me
this is like I imagine I imagine Andrea comes
from like theater so sure I don't know what his
acting background is he strikes me as a theater
performer um but yeah like that moment when
he's digging at him with his uh yeah dentist not
being legit I thought it was a tactic you know and
this and I think the show wants you to think
it's a tactic in that moment yes he was just
actually upset yeah and it's also the perfect
foreshadowing exactly it has to be regarded he
has to be revered you know it has to be respected
and it supports uh Peralta's Revelation that much
more in a way that is completely not obvious
and if it's character based for all three of
them yeah yeah all three of them it was really
character based and surprisingly nuanced and
sometimes when they are doing something that has
more in its mind than the comedy it sometimes the
comedy can feel forced this really did feel like
a natural gel all around yeah totally no no like
100 this it felt like the most natural thing like
somehow I like the the writing the Performing the
circumstances everything just felt So Graceful
and it's like yeah I was never missing jokes
but when they would show up they would catch
me by surprise the moments of intensity were
actually kind of intense and it shot really well
yeah they have some like great lighting um great
Shadows uh the consistency with the interrogation
room a lot like the way they would do the framing
if it was like a close-up on Peralta and you would
constantly have Holt in the mirror being reflected
watching him the entire time and you'd constantly
have Sterling K Brown in the background like doing
little yeah even if he was like way in the back
yeah you can always see him doing something and
it's always something in contrast from being
rattled or whatever it is and two I think
it's paced really nicely because obviously it's
only like 20 minutes but it still feels like you
were there there all night in a way that's not a
detriment or not like oh what a drag but like yeah
I feel like it does when they're finally out in
the dawn light you're like oh yeah like you have
that sort of catharsis a little bit of like when
you you know did something for that many hours
on end and finally succeeded and now you can kind
of rest yeah yeah and then that last moment with
them was just so sweet and and felt really off the
cuff somehow like that thing where he says Kevin
you know as being like the person who's got to
prove how smart he is and they both laugh almost
felt like an improv or something like just the
way you get to snorkel after Halt and like the
way their voice is cracked like I don't know
there's just it just felt like a real sense of
camaraderie behind and in front of the camera or
I guess in life but also in context of the scene
just go to work though they worked massive
overtime I think they can get I think they
would be like hey we so we cracked we got
someone okay yeah we gotta murder confession
yeah can somebody yeah there's got to be a way
for Holt to take a day in Pearl to take a day
you don't want somebody who just pulled
an all-nighter investigating more crimes
I mean I guess it would be easier for Hulk
because he just has to do office things but
damn I I feel like no one's ever talked about
Sterling K Brown's performance I had we had
no idea did you have any idea who's gonna be this
did you read a description beforehand no I didn't
really I had no idea and the thumbnails on this
season for Amazon are just the yellow Brooklyn
Nine-Nine logos yeah I had no idea he was on the
show yeah I had no clue he was on the show yeah
um so and now I'm like but I'm only this is
like a performance that I feel like people would
talk about like like his appearance here yeah I'm
trying to think where this would have been in his
what year this would have been and where that was
in the rise of Sterling K Brown because certainly
in the past handful of years he's been catapulted
to much more sort of like household name status
because he knows how to make ego and narcissism
very Charming he does I mean this reminds me the
hard thing to do this reminded me of a better
version and a more grounded version of that
character he played in The Predator movie where
like you know he's just like Mr cool but here it's
tempered in the right way where it's not just like
oh no one's directing you you're just doing your
thing and having fun yeah and I mean he's good
in that movie too but uh but yeah I don't know
it's just so lovely which is a fun time to be
watching this this woke me up I've had a I didn't
sleep guys at all right we had the Loki trailer
this morning I'm shooting this and when I say I
didn't sleep I really didn't I was I was fostering
cats and um you had to interrogate there's one cat
who was like five cats and there was one cat who's
still learning how to use the bathroom properly
and uh didn't notice that the blank because I was
I didn't notice it peed on my blanket and I didn't
know it's like three in the morning and I was like
well I can't leave this spot where I'm at because
I want to make sure they feel safe right now yeah
so I'm just gonna try to lay here even though
and then uh it was one of those nights where I
was just like laying down with my eyes closed
but I never actually fell asleep oh sure yeah yeah
I reached six in the morning in the Loki Church
yeah I'm very I'm very well it was very sorry
before we shot this I'm like wow this woke me
up that was great that was really good
yeah that's powerful I'm feeling what
they're feeling yeah yeah well time to
go back into work well guys leave us
your thoughts on the episode what did you
think is it one of the best of all time
I mean like I think there's an argument to be made
for like well maybe the best episode has more of
the Ensemble but this is absolutely suck screw
all those people care what are even their names
Gina Jim Boyle oh you're getting them right
um Rosa that girl from Encanto yeah Alfred
Hitchcock the woman on that Blockbuster show
older and Scully and uh that America's Got Talent
host yeah um America's got a Canon Nick Cannon
America's gotten again well guys what's your
favorite v99 episode and why is it this one
comment below and we'll catch you next
week it's another two for peacock [Music]